in September of 2008 something
unheard-of happened in the art world a
British artist Damien Hirst took two
hundred and twenty three pieces of his
new work to saw the Beast auction house
and sold every single piece I'll start
the bidding here at two million five
hundred thousand pounds at two million
five it was a two-day event and the
total sale was about two hundred million
dollars it broke the record for single
artist auction of twenty million dollars
back in 1993 Hurst's work included
things like the zebra this unicorn and
this painting made from butterflies so
how did he how do artists do this well
for the most part the artists aren't the
ones behind it okay so obviously money
isn't the only value that defines a work
of art and who knows how history will
remember this unicorn but in order to
sell a million-dollar artwork you need
strong market value and you need
extremely high demand and a ton of work
goes into creating that assam thompson
describes in his book the formula for
art pricing goes something like this
the bigger the work generally the more
expensive it is but the biggest variable
is the reputation of the artist
sometimes your world famous and
sometimes you're not what but when a new
artist steps into the art market the
reputation of the artists heavily relies
on the name of the dealer the shark by
Damien Hirst
is a good example Hirst first began
working with an art industry giant
Orochi in the 1990s Saatchi commissioned
Hirst to make anything you wanted for
50,000 pounds after seeing this cow's
head at a show shortly after Hearst
graduation in 99 II Hearst bought a
shark for 6,000 pounds from an
Australian fisherman and created this
injecting it with tons of formaldehyde
later in 2004 it was sold for twelve
million dollars to a billionaire hedge
fund manager Steve Cohen it was roughly
a hundred and thirty times the original
price but it makes sense considering
saachi's reputation and it makes more
sense when you think about how it was
box dealers can use selective
information to get potential buyers to
pay
or Hurst's huge option that I mentioned
before for dealers sold work everything
is private including the prices which
gives dealers the upper hand in pricing
in 1988 New York City tried to ban this
by reinforcing the truth and pricing law
and galleries fought back hard paying
fines and protesting saying that showing
prices will be quote getting in the way
of enjoyment of the exhibition by
keeping the price private our dealers
can rely more on their reputation to
make artwork feel more valuable to the
buyer outside of this equation the basic
laws of economics also applied the next
step of operation for the dealer is
creating scarcity in 1999 when Jenny
Savile a new emerging British artist
became affiliated with Kawasaki he
convinced her to cut her work down to
only six paintings per year he sold them
for $100,000 each so what does this all
result to according to art net the
estimated size of the art market was 64
billion dollars in 2015 and the market
is growing outside of traditional sales
of galleries and auction houses this
chart shows the art world might be
learning the lesson Sachi taught Jenny
Savile the total value of the art that's
being sold is growing faster than the
number of pieces so less of it for more
but to sell that million-dollar art work
you'll need reputation bigger than hers
or atrocities the dealer model still
dominates the fine art world but for the
rest of us selling art online has never
been easier the prices are open and it's
accessible for a broad group of people
and for one thing now you know where to
start think big